So, before we jump into these questions, let's talk
a bit about how to approach these assignments. Most
of these questions won't have a correct answer. Rather
than asking you to choose the correct definition of user
experience we're actually going to ask you to do some
design. We're also going to ask a lot of questions where
the only output from you to us is your
response to the question, did you do this? Now obviously,
the purpose of a question like this is not to
prevent plagiarism. The assumption here is you are in this course,
you want to learn how to improve your design skills. And,
anyways, if you are actually enrolled in the class, your final
grade of pass or no pass will be based only on
your final project. So, the purpose of a question like this
is really to help you keep track of the questions you've
answered and which ones you haven't. You get that nice little
orange bubble filled in somewhere up here in the
navigation when you've completed a question. And, another part of
the reason why we ask these questions is for
us, and for the continued improvement of this class. We
want to know if the people taking this class
are doing the assignments. We're also going to ask you
to submit to the forum quite a bit. And let
me actually talk about that a bit more. So working
on this course with Nasman and Isabel has
been awesome. Pretty early into the design of
this class, we realized that the design process
that. We at Udacity have sort of converged on
over the last few years, is essentially identical
to the design process that Nasman and Isabelle
advocate for, in the world of software. One
example of this, in less than four, you are
going to learn how to take the things that
Android can do really well and leverage those opportunities to
make amazing experiences for your users. But, more generally what
I think's going on here is, you should know as
a designer, what you are uniquely positioned to do
well. No matter what you're designing. And then you should
do that thing well. In these massive classes that we've
been making for a while now, we've realized that one
thing we are uniquely positioned to do
well is leverage this amazing, massive body of
enthusiastic, diverse, intelligent students who are all thinking
and doing projects about the same sort of
stuff. And that's, that's a really huge
learning opportunity. So when we ask you to
write something down or share something in the
forum. That's, that's why. We want you to
not only learn from the writing experience itself, but to
share that with other students and read what other students
have to say. This, this sort of social learning is
a really potentially important part of the online learning experience